نحن على بعد تقريبا اربعين كيلو متر في
قريه قريبه من تابعه لمدينه كهرمان مرش
هذه تعرضت الى دمار من نوع اخر دمار نريد
ان نعطيكم صوره هذا الدمار بشكل اوسع حيث
احد الطرق التي
تدمرت بشكل كبير واحدث الزلزال فيها شرخا
هائلا بحيث تدخلت الارض ببعضها في هذه
المنطقه هذه منطقه مدينه
تشيجيلي التابعه لشهرمان مرش اصبحت هي
مقطوعه في هذا الجزئها الشمالي اصبحت
مقطوعه عن بقيه الاجزاء الاخرى ونحن
استغرقنا وقتا طويلا حتى نصل الى هذا
المكان باعتبار ان معظم الطرق اصبحت
متشققه ومدمره هذا هو الجزء الاكبر دمارا
في هذه المنطقه حيث احدث زلزال مشهدا
مرعبا في هذا الطريق الواصل بين جهتي هذه
القريه قريه جيجلي عندما تجولنا في القريه
شاهدنا العديد من ساكني القريه بيوتهم
ليست مدمره لكنهم
يسكنون في الخيام خيام تابعه لمؤسسه اداره
الطوارئ الكارثه التركيه افاد خوفا من
الهزات الارتداديه التي تحصل في في
المنطقه